progression je suis régulièrement
interrogé je ne comprends pas monsieur
le premier ministre je suis vacciné j'ai
même reçu les trois doses et pourtant
j'ai contracté le vario micro alors la
vaccination ne serait-elle pas efficace
la réponse est claire si la vaccination
n'empêche manif est régulièrement
interrogé je ne comprends pas de se
rendre m je l'aï vacciné d'abord elle
j'ai reçu mes trois risquent d'être
contaminés et ce risque de transmettre
la maladie mais surtout surtout elle
prémunit contre les formes graves de
l'aco vide et cela reste vrai pour le
variant omicron surtout lorsque l'on à
ces trois doses ou deux doses plus la
maladie donc oui il est très clair que
la vaccination nous protège et que par
voie de conséquence elle protège les
autres et elle protège les services de
santé soumis à très rude épreuve là
encore les faits sont là dans tous les
services de soins critiques l'immense
majorité des personnes hospitalisées
avec des formes graves de l'aco vide ne
sont pas vaccinés ou n'ont pas de
couverture vaccinale complète j'ai
parcourir la france des services de
réanimation pour dire un lassabe le mans
au personnel mon soutien et mon
admiration et je peux vous dire qu'il
n'ya pas photo sur la nature des
hospitalisations et des formes graves ce
sont des personnes non vaccinées ou des
malades vacciner mais atteint de
comorbidités graves
l'élément que les décisif est et demeure
la vaccination voilà pourquoi comme je
voulais dit lors de ma précédente
intervention nous faisons tout pour
accélérer et renforcer la vaccination
faire peser la contrainte sur les non
vaccinés tout en cherchant à aller vers
et à convaincre celles et ceux de nos
concitoyens qui sont encore très
éloignées du système de soins nous avons
ouvert sur la base du volontariat la
vaccination aux enfants de 5 à 11 ans en
priorisant ceux d'entre eux par ailleurs
atteint d'autres pathologies dès demain
matin suivant en cela la recommandation
de la haute autorité de santé il suffira
de trois mois après votre deuxième
injection ou votre première si vous avez
eu le coc vide pour pouvoir bénéficier
de votre rappel nous avons réalisé de
magnifiques performances collectives en
matière de vaccination en ce mois de
décembre
y compris avec une reprise salutaire est
indispensable des premières injections
il y a eu un ralentissement pendant
cette période de fêtes mais nous devons
absolument repartir de l'avant et je
veux à cet égard dire ma reconnaissance
et mes remerciements à toutes celles et
ceux qui sont fortement mobilisés pour
vacciner et aussi pour tester je pense
bien sûr aux professionnels de santé
tous confondus avec des pharmaciens
d'officine particulièrement sollicités
mais également au centre de vaccination
et à toutes celles et tous ceux qui en
assurent la gestion élus locaux et
notamment les maires personnels des
collectivités territoriales
sapeurs-pompiers grandes associations
caritatives et solidaire professionnels
de santé souvent retraités étudiants
bénévoles ils forment tous avec les
services de l'état préfets et agences
régionales de santé éducation nationale
santé au travail est désormais le
concours de militaires une formidable
chaîne de solidarité pour vous protéger
et répondre à ce défi qui est devant
nous à croître encore et encore la
vaccination première deuxième et
troisième dose dans les jours et
semaines à venir le conseil des
ministres d'aujourd'hui
à
dans le même objectif adopter un projet
de loi qui va transformer le pass
sanitaires on passe vaccinale cela
signifie que dans les lieux où se
passent s'applique depuis plusieurs mois
les restaurants les bars les musées les
théâtres les médiathèques les séminaires
et salons les salles de sport les
enceintes sportives et de spectacles il
faudra justifier d'être vacciné pour
pouvoir entrer la production d'un test
ne suffira plus cette nouvelle règle si
elle est votée par le parlement
s'appliquera à compter du 15 janvier
prochain le projet de loi prévoit
également un accroissement des sanctions
contre les faux parce je veux vous dire
combien cette pratique me scandalise
comme premier ministre bien sûr mais
comme citoyen c'est beaucoup plus qu'un
contournement de la loi républicaine
déjà en soi très condamnable c'est un
acte délibéré de mise en danger d'autrui
aucune conviction personnelle ne saurait
le justifier ce n'est pas admissible et
nous devons collectivement nous donner
les moyens de l'enrayer et de le
sanctionner plus lourdement
au delà de nos efforts pour préserver et
renforcer notre bouclier
vaccinale contre le virus et ses
différents variant nous devons aussi
adapter nos mesures pour faire face aux
deux vagues liées à la fois au delta et
a omis crohn qui nous atteignent au même
moment et dans les effets et les risques
doivent être analysé au regard d'un
critère essentiel
les risque de formes graves et la
situation de nos hôpitaux comme olivier
vers en le développant dans un instant
ce que nous observons depuis trois
semaines environ en grande bretagne au
danemark
justifie à la fois prudence et vigilance
si l'on ne voit pas à ce stade 2 sur
charge hospitalière lié à omicron la
très forte contagiosité de ce variant la
vitesse à laquelle il se propage doivent
nous conduire au delà de la priorité
vaccinale à prolonger et amplifier de
manière proportionnée nos mesures pour
freiner sa circulation soulager nos
services hospitaliers et éviter la
désorganisation de notre économie nous
sommes engagés dans une course contre la
montre dans le prolongement des
dispositions déjà prises notamment la
fermeture des discothèques
nous avons aujourd'hui adopter les
mesures complémentaires suivantes qui
s'appliqueront à compter de lundi
prochain pour une durée de trois
semaines pour freiner omicron les grands
rassemblements seront limités à une
jauge de 2000 personnes maximum un
intérieur et 5000 personnes maximum un
extérieur les concerts debout seront
interdit la consommation de boissons et
d'aliments sera interdite dans tous les
cinémas les théâtres les équipements
sportifs et les transports collectifs y
compris longue distance la consommation
dans les bars et cafés ne pourra plus se
faire seulement deux bouts mais
seulement de manière à 6 pour le
réveillon du 31 janvier je vous
renouvelle annie insistant les
recommandations que j'avais émise le 17
décembre dernier limitons les grandes
fêtes et les grands dîners portant le
masque à héron les pièces respectons les
gestes barrière testons nous toutes
mesures de bon sens qui font confiance à
notre sens des responsabilités
toutes les cérémonies de voeux prévue en
janvier seront par ailleurs annulés à
compter de la rentrée et pour une durée
de trois semaines le recours au
télétravail sera rendue obligatoire je
dis bien obligatoire dans toutes les
entreprises et pour tous les salariés
lequel il est possible à raison de trois
jours minimum par semaine et si possible
quatre jours quand cela est possible
elisabeth bornes la ministre chargé du
travail mènera demain une concertation
avec les partenaires sociaux
par ailleurs l'obligation du masque déjà
partout applicable à l'intérieur sera
étendue et mieux respecter notamment
dans tous les centres villes les préfets
adopteront les dispositions
correspondantes en lien avec les maires
à ce stade notre volonté d'adapter nos
dispositifs de manière proportionnée
nous conduit à écarter toute mesure de
couvre feu nous referons le point à
l'occasion d'un prochain conseil de
défense convoqué le 5 janvier prochain
domaine s'agissant des établissements
d'enseignement nous resterons dans la
ligne que nous nous sommes fixés depuis
le début de la pandémie à savoir de ne
les ferme et qu'en dernier recours c'est
pour cette raison que nous ne
reporteront pas la rentrée ne
basculeront les collèges et les lycées
en distance yale de ce point de vue la
communication de ce jour des sociétés
savantes de pédiatrie est sans équivoque
et va totalement dans ce sens bien
entendu nous amplifierons à la rentrée
notre politique de surveillance et de
dépistage dans les établissements
scolaires au vu des données
épidémiologiques dans des conditions que
vous précisera olivier verrons de même
les caractéristiques domique rhône vont
nous conduire après avis des autorités
sanitaires à ajuster notre doctrine sur
la durée d'isolement lorsque vous êtes
positif ou lorsque vous n'êtes qu'à
contacter nous fixerons ces règles
nouvelles d'ici la fin de la semaine une
fois achevées les consultations de nos
instances scientifiques il s'agira à la
fois d'adapter ses durée en fonction du
variant et là encore de faire peser une
contrainte moindre sur les personnes
vaccinées
les secteurs économiques impacté par les
décisions que la situation nous commande
de prendre seront indemnisés dans le
cadre de concertation qui seront sans
délai conduite par le ministre de
l'économie et des finances bruno le
maire enfin des dispositions spécifiques
aux territoires d'outre-mer ont été
adoptés tout à l'heure par le conseil
des ministres concernant en particulier
l'île de la réunion où l'état d'urgence
sanitaire sera déclarée et la martinique
où il sera prolongé
mes chers concitoyens j'ai parfaitement
conscience de la situation qui est la
nôtre croyez bien que je la partage je
comprends que les mesures annoncées
que nous avons voulu comme toujours
proportionnée à la réalité de la
situation et à ses évolutions
prévisibles je comprends que ces mesures
puissent parfois suscité une forme de
ras-le-bol mais le président de la
république comme son gouvernement ne
cherche depuis le début de la crise qu à
vous protéger
nous avons une stratégie dont nous
essayons de préserver la cohérence tout
en l'adaptant aux évolutions de la
pandémie priorité à la vaccination en la
complétant de mesures adaptées et
évolutives en fonction des vagues et
précisément des variants faire peser le
plus possible la contrainte sur les
non-vaccinés
maintenir autant que faire se peut les
écoles ouvertes dans l'intérêt même des
enfants et avec des protocoles
sanitaires adaptés assuré dans un cadre
protecteur à l'exercice du travail et la
continuité de la vie de la nation tout
laisse tout cela semble un film qui n'en
finit pas pourtant quel changement avec
la situation
il ya un an il y a un an jour pour jour
morissette était la première française à
se faire vacciner
aujourd'hui nous sommes grâce à la
mobilisation collective l'un des peuples
les plus vacciner au monde donc le mieux
protégé et bien nous devons poursuivre
amplifier ce mouvement pour faire face à
la nouvelle vague épidémique et le futur
texte de loi va nous y aider je sais
bien que nous devons poursuivre nos
efforts dans un combat qui peut parfois
sembler sens mais ce combat ensemble par
l'esprit de responsabilité et de
solidarité nous le gagnerons le
gagneront aussi un accroissant notre
attention aux pays les plus pauvres et
la france doit être fière d'être la
troisième nation au monde à donner des
doses de vaccin à ces pays restons
mobilisés
restons rassemblé restons déterminés
il n'ya pas d'autre voie pour faire face
et surmonter cette pandémie monsieur le
ministre des solidarités et la santé
merci monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs nous faisons pas
si vous l'avez dit à deux vagues
simultanées qui sont liées à deux
variants différents et kenneth qui
nécessite donc deux types de mesures
différentes mais complémentaires afin de
les freiner il ya d'abord le variant
delta on le connaît depuis plusieurs
semaines plusieurs mois dans notre pays
on en connaît les caractéristiques la
dangerosité ce variant qui a envahi la
planète ou presque et qui continue de
sévir dans notre pays puisque après
avoir une stabilisation du nombre de cas
un pic qui a été atteint vers la début
le début du mois de décembre
si on constate dans certaines régions
une diminution des contaminations aux
variants delta dans d'autres ils
continuent à augmenter et au global on
est sur une forme de plateau nous
n'avons donc pas terminé encore note
combat contre ce variant delta alors
même que nous menons cette bataille ce
nouveau variant est arrivé le variant
omicron en provenance d'afrique australe
et c'est invariant qui circule si vite
qu'à l' inverse des précédents variant
nous n'avons pas suffisamment de recul
en provenance de pays qui aurait été
touché avant nous pour maîtriser
totalement les tenants et aboutissants
de ce variant on a néanmoins quelques
semaines par rapport à l'afrique du sud
et une dizaine de jours environ par
rapport à l'angleterre et au danemark
qui sont les pays les plus touchés je le
dis ce variant est en train de traverser
toute la planète
l'espagne l'italie qui avait été
relativement épargnée par le variante
lta connaissent aujourd'hui des pics
épidémiques en tout cas des montées
épidémie qui ne sont pas aux pics qui
dépasse tout ce qu'ils ont connu depuis
le début de la pandémie alors à l'heure
actuelle quels sont nos certitudes
concernant ce variant omicron d'abord on
sait qu mikron est beaucoup beaucoup
plus contagieux que les variants
précédent et notamment que le variant
delta au moins trois fois plus
contagieux le temps de doublement c'est
à dire le nombre de malades contaminés
double tous les deux jours s'étaient
tous les douze à quinze jours avec le
variant delta c'est pour ça que si vous
regardez la courbe si vous êtes attentif
on passe de dix mille à cent mille cas
par jour en l'espace de quelques jours
et tout laisse à penser que ça va
continuer à monter que nous pouvions
atteindre nous disent certains
modélisateurs plus de 250 mille cas par
jour d'ici au début du mois de janvier
ce qui est hors proportion par rapport à
ce que nous avons connu depuis le début
de la pandémie
deuxième constat mme omicron a cette
capacité archontes aminés des personnes
qui ont déjà attrapé le coc vide et même
des personnes qui ont eu des formes
symptomatiques voir des formes
symptomatiques sévère du coc vide cette
proportion a contaminé change aussi la
donne on peut donc retomber malade si on
attrape le omicron problème constat au
micro d est moins sensible aux vaccins
que le variant delta mais c'est une
bonne nouvelle la troisième dose quand
on est à jour de son rappel fait
immédiatement remonter le niveau de
protection au dessus de 90 % même bien
au-dessus de 90 % face au risque de
formes graves les personnes à risque
restent donc les personnes non vaccinées
les personnes vaccinées mais qui sont
très fragiles parce qu'elle très âgés ou
parce qu'elles souffrent
d'immunodépression et puis les personnes
qui ont un schéma vaccinal qui n'est pas
complet c'est-à-dire les personnes qui
ont eu deux doses mais pas encore leur
troisième c'est d'ailleurs le sens de l'
annonce que vous venez de faire et qui
reprend la proposition de la haute
autorité de santé de dire on n'attend
pas quatre ou cinq mois pour faire son
rappel des trois mois après la dernière
injection ou après la dernière
infections on peut recevoir cette
troisième dose une vaccination complète
éloigne le risque de formes graves
éloigne le risque de réanimation même si
vous deviez contracté le virus
quatrième et dernier constat omicron
parce qu'il contamine vite et fort il
est responsable aujourd'hui de très
nombreux ce personne positive donc dont
certains malades mais également de très
nombreux cas contact et ça représente
donc un risque majeur d'absentéisme on
le voit déjà une hausse très forte et
des arrêts de travail ce qui peut avoir
un impact sur notre système de soins
quand ça touche les soignants on le
constate dans certains pays européens
mais ça peut aussi avoir un impact sur
l'activité de nos entreprises et de
façon générale sur la vie du pays si
nous avons des certitudes nous avons
encore des incertitudes
d'abord est il vrai que omicron est
moins dangereux c'est la question
centrale si omicron était aussi
dangereux que delta vu sa vitesse de
circulation on comprend qu'il mettrait
rapidement en péril tous les systèmes de
santé du monde en quelques jours mais
les études dont nous disposons en
provenance d'afrique du sud en
provenance du danemark en provenance du
royaume uni semble montrer que les
hospitalisations sont peu nombreuses et
pour des motifs moins graves à titre
d'exemple les besoin d'oxygène des
malades hospitalisés sont moins
importants et les durée moyenne
d'hospitalisation sont plus courts ce
qui est évidemment une très bonne
nouvelle si elle devait se confirmer si
elle devait être confirmée par ce qu'il
y ait encore des billets dans cette
étude notamment le variant au bik ron
actuellement dans ces pays touche
contamine surtout des pc des personnes
qui sont jeunes et aussi d'ailleurs le
cas en france et on sait que les gens
jeunes vont moins souvent l'hôpital or
on sait qu inévitablement quand les
jeunes sont touchés par le virus au bout
d'un moment ce sont des personnes moins
jeunes qui finissent par être touchés et
donc ont message vraiment destiné aux
personnes fragiles ou parce qu'elles
sont malades parce qu'elles sont âgés
surtout si vous êtes en attente de votre
troisième dose de vaccin faites
attention à vous limitez vos
déplacements prenez garde face à ce
variant pour lequel on a encore cette
part d'inconnu plus grande vigilance
donc comme annoncé par le premier
ministre et tenant compte des avis des
autorités sanitaires nous rabaissons le
délai je le disais à trois mois ce qui
veut dire que désormais ce sont plus de
45 millions de nos concitoyens qui sont
concernés par le rappel la moitié a déjà
reçu ce rappel 22 millions et demi ce
soir donc nous allons y arriver ensemble
grâce à la mobilisation extraordinaire
des centres et des libéraux
deuxième incertitude est ce que omicron
va entraîner une vague épidémique
explosive mais brève pourquoi je pose
cette question parce qu on observe en
afrique du sud après une montée très
forte du nombre de cas une diminution
rapide et aussi importante du nombre de
contaminations mais attention parce que
dans ce pays d'abord ce sont les
vacances estivales et donc ça peut
changer la donne en terme de
contamination et c'est également un pays
qui a été fortement touchée par les
variants précédent avec un niveau
d'immunité collectif plus fort mais
enfin bon on n'est pas à l'abri d'une
bonne nouvelle est évidemment nous
souhaitons ardemment que cette vague
soit la plus courte possible
autre incertitude est ce que omicron
peut être freiné par des mesures
totalement classiques tels que nous
avons pu en mettre en place dans notre
pays a priori le danemark qui est mis en
place un certain nombre de mesures n'a
pas constaté d'effet de freinage sur la
dynamique épidémique parce que mikron
est tellement contagieux qu'hormis
finalement un confinement généralisée
rien ne semble capable d'en freiner la
course en tout cas aucun pays à date n'a
pu totalement le freiner dans sa
dynamique de croissance épidémique en
revanche et c'est le sens des annonces
qui ont été faites par le premier
ministre on constate qu'ils nous avons
tout intérêt à limiter les grands
rassemblements pourquoi parce que dans
les grands rassemblements il y à des
risques que quelqu'un puisse entraîner
la contamination d'un maximum de
personnes autour de lui et que cela a un
effet qui accentue la dynamique de
l'épidémie et donc c'est pour ça que
nous voulons mettre fin par exemple aux
situations qui permettait vous le voyez
quand vous sortez de retirer son masque
et le temps de boire ou le temps de
manger comme par exemple quand on est au
cinéma c'est parce que c'est pourquoi
désormais le port du masque sera
obligatoire toute la durée de la séance
ce sera le cas dans cet établissement
recevant du public et c'est pourquoi
aussi il ya des limitations du nombre de
personnes dans les gradins dès
maintenant les grands rassemblements qui
vient d'être décidées et annoncées par
le premier ministre pour les trois
prochaines semaines
dernière incertitude escaut micron va
freiner la vague delta qui est toujours
en circulation dans notre pays et dont
l'impact sanitaire continue d'augmenter
ou est-ce qu'il va créer ce que j'avais
appelé un phénomène de lame de fond
c'est à dire une forme de mega vague
constituée des deux vagues qui chemine
chacun de leur côté je les dis pour
rouleurs si delta a cessé d'augmenter
dans notre pays il se maintient à un
niveau élevé en plateau dans certaines
régions il continue même d'augmenter et
c'est ce qui justifie notamment
l'obligation de télétravail que vous
venez d'annoncer monsieur le premier
ministre parce que le télétravail est
très efficace sur un variant qui est
moins contagieux que le variant mikron
comme le variant delta c'est pour ça
c'est vraiment le rationnel de
combinaison des différentes mesures pour
arriver à freiner les faits des deux
vagues qui se cumulent je le rappelle
parmi les risques que nous identifions
il ya l'impact sur la société d'une
multiplication des contaminations et des
cas contact qui peut entraîner une
paralysie des services publics et privés
à l'instar de nombreux voisins et compte
tenu des caractéristiques propres aux
variants omicron nous avons saisi le
haut conseil de santé publique qui
émettra des recommandations cette fin de
semaine probablement d'ailleurs le 31
décembre en vue d'alléger les conditions
d'isolement des cas contactez dernier
point monsieur le premier ministre une
question qui revient beaucoup et qui est
profondément légitime qui concerne les
enfants vous en avait parlé oui il le
virus circule chez les enfants il
circule à l'école ils circulent à la
maison c'est pourquoi d'ailleurs un
protocole scolaires sanitaires a été
élaboré c'est pourquoi il est révisé
régulièrement en fonction de l'état de
circulation du virus est en fonction de
l'état des connaissances scientifiques
oui nous assumons de sanctuariser
l'éducation des enfants un enfant qui ne
va pas à l'école est un enfant qui peut
rencontrer de graves difficultés et là
c'est le ministre en charge des
solidarités qui parle et c'est
d'ailleurs également compliqué vous le
savez quand vous l'avez vécu à la maison
oui il arrive que les enfants dans de
rares situations et surtout lorsqu'ils
souffrent par ailleurs déjà de maladies
sous jacentes puisse développer des
formes
av à date 190 enfants sont hospitalisés
en france pour qu'ovide 35 enfants sont
même en service de réanimation c'est
vrai et c'est pour cette raison
notamment que nous avons ouvert la
vaccination aux enfants âgés de 5 à 11
ans la semaine dernière et je vous
donnais une comparaison chaque année la
bronchiolite entraîne l'hospitalisation
de 23 mille enfants 23 mille enfants en
comparaison aux chiffres que j'ai donné
ses quatorze mille enfants qui sont
admis à l'hôpital chaque année en raison
de la fameuse gastro entérite est
actuellement il ya plus d'enfants
hospitalisés en réanimation pédiatrique
en raison d'une bronchiolite en raison
d'une forme grave du coc vie de chaque
année c'est en moyenne deux à trois
mille enfants qui vont en réanimation
pour cause de bronchiolite et pour
autant la vie est importante dans les
crèches auprès des assistantes
maternelles dans les petits niveaux
scolaires elle ne s'arrête pas à chaque
fois que l'épidémie ne redémarre mais
néanmoins c'est pourquoi nous mettons en
place des mesures encore une fois de
protection une bonne décision de santé
publique c'est une décision médicale
mais c'est aussi une décision sociétale
évidemment si de nouvelles données
devaient apparaître en france ou à
l'étranger sur l'impact du variant
omicron chez les enfants nous pourrions
être amenés à prendre toute mesure utile
pour les protéger et dans l'intervalle
nous continuerons à travailler avec le
ministre de l'éducation nationale pour
renforcer les mesures qui sont
susceptibles de réduire les risques
notamment la question de l'aération de
l'équipement des classes qui ne le sont
pas encore en capteur de co2 pour vous
dire quand il est temps d'ouvrir les
fenêtres et la porte mais également le
système de test itératif et de dépistage
systématique par test salivaire
notamment qui a été mis en place depuis
plusieurs mois désormais dans notre pays
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre dont
nous allons d'ordre quelques questions
si vous le voulez bien
bonjour monsieur le premier ministre
bonjour monsieur mise de la santé
mathieu coatch bfm tv le conseil
scientifique a fait part de son
inquiétude sur une possible des
organisations de la société à la rentrée
à cause des arrêts maladies qui sont
très nombreux considérez vous que ces
mesures celles que vous venez d'annoncer
vont empêcher cette désorganisation et
une possible paralysie de l'économie
puis j'ai une deuxième question que vous
avez fait référence au faux-pas
sanitaire qui circulent
que prévoyez vous concrètement pour
empêcher leur circulation
ce que l'ajout d'une photo par exemple
sur les pass est envisagée ou bien une
vérification d'identité systématiques à
l'entrée des lieux où ils sont
obligatoires je vous remercie
peut-être de deux trois questions à la
suite si vous voulez bien le contre
france info vous annoncez ramener le
délai pour la vacciner pour la troisième
dose à trois mois les plus de 65 ans
peuvent se faire vacciner de cette
troisième dose depuis début septembre
est ce que ça veut dire que d'ores et
déjà ils peuvent prendre rendez vous
pour leur quatrième dose un doute heures
bonjour monsieur bonjour monsieur le
premier ministre bonjour monsieur minier
de la santé thomas des prix rtl que
quelle mesure prenez vous pour les
meetings politiques
est-ce que les jauges concerne également
les meetings de la campagne
présidentielle aujourd'hui on le sait le
pass sanitaires n'étaient pas exigée
pour ses meetings
on s'arrête là pour ce premier jeu
commence il voulait bien par la dernière
question pardon mais juste pour vous
rappelez vous rappelez pardon pour
rappeler à celles et ceux qui nous
écoutent que
l'exercice du culte d'une part et les
activités politiques et électorales
d'autre part sont soumises à des
dispositions spécifiques dans notre
droit constitutionnel qui le rassure on
va dire une protection encore plus forte
donc il est clair que les mesures
répondre à votre question que j'ai
annoncée ce soir ne concerne pas les
meetings politiques compte tenu de cette
spécificité par ailleurs pour préparer
la campagne électorale plus de manière
plus générale parce qu à pas cher
monsieur que la question des réunions
publiques que vous venez d'évoquer le
ministre de l'intérieur en se
rapprochant évidemment du conseil
constitutionnel et je vous rappelle un
rôle majeur notamment dans
l'organisation des élections
présidentielles
réunira sans doute une commission un peu
comme nous l'avions fait pour les
élections régionales contre associant
toutes les formations politiques pour
nous accorder on va dire sur des règles
qui soient évidemment protectrice par
rapport à la situation sanitaire mais
qui tiennent compte de la spécificité
de cette activité fondamentale c'est à
dire finalement de l'exercice de là
graphique avant de passer la parole à
olivier
olivier ferrand effectivement par
rapport à la première question relative
à la désorganisation de l'économie à la
l'un des derniers avis rendu à ce sujet
par le par le conseil scientifique c'est
tout l'enjeu me semble-t-il de la non ce
que nous avons fait avec le ministre des
solidarités de la santé de l'adaptation
de la notion de cas positifs et surtout
2,4 contacter si vous relisez en
particulier l'avis en question
aux variants omicron tout se tient c'est
à dire que effectivement s'il présente
des formes moins graves tout en étant
beaucoup plus contagieux il faut que les
autorités sanitaires j'insiste auprès de
vous nous fasse des propositions nous
les avons saisis comme l'indiqué olivier
verrons nous disposerons tous à vendredi
normalement le 31 c'est ça et à l'issue
de l'ensemble de ces propositions nous
vous annoncerons les dispositions
concrètes que nous retiendrons pour
effectivement nous nous prémunir le plus
possible de cette désorganisation
potentielles liées comme vous l'avez
bien compris à la contagiosité est très
forte de ce variant monsieur le ministre
sur les autres questions sur les autres
questions y avait une question sur les
contrôles du faux-pas sanitaires dont
c'est vrai que le texte le projet de loi
gouvernemental et le débat parlementaire
devrait aborder la question du contrôle
d'identité
pour limiter le recours est l'impact
néfaste de de ses faux-pas sanitaire ce
sera un point de discussion important il
avait déjà été discutée dans un
précédent texte de loi n'y avait pas eu
de majorité qui s'étaient fait jour au
parlement je pense que la situation a
changé et de la même manière j'entends
que des parlementaires des groupes
d'opposition qui jusqu'ici ont voté
contre le past and i terres 10
que désormais ils sont prêts à
accompagner la transformation de ce pas
cela était en passe vaccinale signe
qu'on apprend tout ce qu'on évolue tous
et je le redis est sans aucune ambiguïté
si on arrive à avoir des consensus dans
les bas parlementaire ce sera forcément
oui juste pour préciser ce que prévoit
après l'avis du conseil d'état parce que
pour un prêt sensible le texte qui a été
délibéré cet après midi en compagnie sur
la question précise que vous soulevez
d'abord que les forces de l'ordre
pourront accéder aux le rp pour procéder
à ces contrôles parce qu'il y avait eu
des manques de clarté des textes en
vigueur et donc des jurisprudences
divergentes et surtout que les
exploitants de rp auront la possibilité
en cas de doute avéré de vérifier
eux-mêmes les entités je sais que c'est
un sujet difficile pour lequel je vais
être très clair dans ma réponse nous
allons surtout mobilisé les forces de
sécurité intérieures mais mais je crois
que c'était votre question le texte de
loi fera effectivement il avancé en ce
sens attends de voir attendant de voir
comme l'a dit le ministre ce que
donneront les débats parlementaires
pardon olivier
l'autre question qui portait c'était sur
la quatrième dose de vaccination c'est
une possibilité
d'ailleurs on voit remonter des demandes
qui émanent de personnes fragiles parce
qu'elles sont âgés ou parce qu'elles
sont malades ont reçu leur troisième
dose en septembre et qui s'inquiète de
savoir si elles doivent à nouveau
réactualiser leur vaccination pour
pouvoir être protégés dans la durée
contre le vario mikron il faut qu'on
puisse leur apporter une réponse je n'ai
pas la réponse à vous apporter
aujourd'hui on travaille au niveau
international avec les homologues
européens avec israël pourquoi israël
parce que ils ont commencé la campagne
de rappel plutôt que le reste de la
planète et donc ils sont capables de
nous dire avant les autres si le niveau
d'immunité faire la capacité à combattre
le virus que confère la troisième dose
de vaccin diminue avec le temps comme
c'était le cas pour le deuxième
injection et s'il convient de faire une
quatrième injection dont je n'ai pas la
réponse formelle à vous donner je vous
dis juste qu'on est totalement ouvert à
cette perspective est que le plus
simplement du monde en transparence et
le plus naturellement du monde s'il faut
aller devant les français pour leur dire
qu'une nouvelle dose de vaccination est
nécessaire pour protéger les plus
fragiles nous le ferons parce que je
considère que la vaccination est une
chance je comprends que ça puisse être
embêtant de prendre rendez-vous d'aller
se faire vacciner qui ça puisse soulever
des inquiétudes mais je suis en ce
moment beaucoup plus ceci par des gens
qui sont plus inquiets à l'idée de ne
plus être suffisamment protégé donc
cette question viendra en son temps pas
maintenant
observé d'ailleurs comme moi je pense
c'est des observateurs attentifs que le
gouvernement israélien qui est
effectivement pour toutes les raisons
qu'a indiqué monsieur véran bonne avance
puisque la troisième dose a été
administré à blain peu avant les autres
pays avaient commencé par faire une
annonce en disant on va faire la 4e et
puis à 10 pour l'instant je sur soi mama
décision donc en fait je pense ce qu'il
faut comme toujours un que quand on
observe les effets de la troisième dans
la durée est ce que ces effets sont
longs et
évite une quatrième si au contraire nous
avons médicalement des indices disant
que ce n'est pas le cas évidemment je
pense qu'il n'y a pas de doute sur le
fait que nous ouvrirons cette quatrième
dose afin la possibilité de
l'administrer mais encore une fois on
n'a pas le recul sur la durée de l'étude
a cité on sait que c'est très excité
c'est quand on est vaccinés ont fait que
l'efficacité maximale une fois qu'on a
eu une injection de rappel et qu'ensuite
elle peut décliner avec le temps on
verra ce qu'il aurait pour la troisième
dose voilà
allez un autre petit jeu de questions
vient d'annoncer le premier monsieur le
ministre une question pour ces news
concernant la vaccination à des
personnalités et des personnes les plus
âgées notamment les 80 ans et plus c'est
la population la plus fragile elle la
tranche d'âge la moins vacciner est ce
que vous prévoyez des mesures pour aller
encore plus vers cette personne ces
personnes potentiellement isolés comme
le porte à porte comme le font à nos
voisins britanniques par exemple
la porte on en fait depuis des mois pas
des semaines des mois les ccas et dans
les collectivités appel on est fiché des
personnes qui sont fragiles de par leur
âge puisque chaque année les appels
l'été quand la canicule les maires les
appelle les médecins généralistes ont
les fichiers de tous ces patients et les
appels était de les convaincre les
infirmiers à domicile font beaucoup de
vaccination de personnes âgées isolées
les familles les amis tout le tout
l'entourage il y à un nombre de
personnes quelques centaines de milliers
alors il et on ne l'estiment pas aux
chiffres près mais il ya encore des
personnes qui sont âgés et qui refusent
le vaccin je ne crois pas qu à ce stade
ce soit quelqu'un qui ne soit pas
informé et je redis que depuis plus de
six mois désormais nous en voyons si
besoin une ambulance à la maison
gratuitement chercher la personne pour
la vacciner à la maison et que tous les
effecteurs sont disponibles on continue
d'avancer de progresser mais il ya
encore des gens savent et c'est parfois
des gens qui sont centenaires et qui
vous dit deux mois m'embêter avec votre
truc c'est vraiment le genre de
situation qui sont rencontrés par contre
pour les primo vaccination vers les gens
qui jusqu'ici ne voulait pas se faire
vacciner ce qu'ils aient j'attends le
vaccin français ou où on n'a pas de
recul ou je risque rien eux sont de plus
en plus nombreux à venir se faire
vacciner près de 35000 un jour comme
aujourd'hui on a eu un pic à 50 milles
sur une journée la semaine dernière on a
fait 200 milles primo vaccination sur
une semaine ce qui est bien ça veut dire
qu'on va regagner on va gagner
progressivement les 53 millions de
français qui ont reçu une injection on
est parmi vraiment les leaders je pense
qu'on est sur le podium européen voire
mondial en termes de couverture
vaccinale si on arrive à convaincre tout
le monde sait qu'on aura bien fait notre
travail si vous me permettez que c'est
une question majeure c'est à dire que
parler de la 3e et de la 4e doors
éventuel la troisième dose c'est très
important ne doit pas nous faire oublier
la première bon il ya encore même si
nous avons sont parmi les pays du monde
on a franchi le fameux seuil de 91 % de
la population éligible primo vaccinées
en france et c'est remarquable et ya
encore des gens qui ne sont pas ça fait
plusieurs centaines de milliers voire
plusieurs millions de la et en
particulier la simu groves est
parfaitement raison madame ce sont les
plus vulnérables comme vous dites des
personnes de plus de 80 ans présente
assurément une exposition et une
vulnérabilité plus grande au virus donc
il faut aller les ché g
je voudrais insister dans ce cas dit
olivier rend une disposition que nous
avons prises en fait la caisse nationale
d'assurance maladie a négocié avec les
syndicats infirmiers
c'est la vaccination à domicile de ces
personnes par des personnes qui les
connaissent bien et qu'ils vont les voir
pour d'autres motifs évidemment que
celui là et qui sont les infirmières
libérales à domicile bon donc nous avons
fortement pré-négociation la cnam a
revalorisé
l'acte vaccinal à domicile fait par les
infirmières libérales est entré en
vigueur il ya peu de jours nous en
attendons évidemment beaucoup puisque en
fait on l'a revalorisé c'est pas une
question tellement pécuniaire mes chats
peuvent chacun peut comprendre que
vacciner quelqu'un il faut le convaincre
il faut attendre les fameuses 15 minutes
qui peuvent être vain j'ai une personne
âgée pour ci a pas d'effets secondaires
est là donc ça prend du temps
l'infirmière n'a pas forcément beaucoup
parce que là énormément de travail donc
on attend beaucoup de cette mesure et
j'observe avec satisfaction à la suite
du ministre que plus globalement le la
simple annonce de l'arrivée fait de la
transformation du pass sanitaire en
passe vaccinale a effectivement conduit
un certain nombre et je les en félicite
de nos concitoyens vers la vaccination
avec des des taux qui sont pas encore
suffisants à mes yeux ma faim qui note
encore aujourd'hui même année c'est un
retour et surtout qui nous rappelle je
pars demain de faire cette réponse
longue mais c'est important que
la primovaccination reste la mère de nos
priorités parce que comme dirait l'autre
c'est difficile d'avoir sa troisième
dose si on n'a pas eu sa première
donnée point un complément pardon
ne prenait pas qu'il y as en réanimation
des gens qui ont 80 90 ans vacciné un
parce que j'entends le discours qui
consiste à dire il suffirait pas chine
et les personnes fragiles qui ne sont
pas encore et de ne pas demander aux
autres de ses racines est factuellement
c'est faux factuellement si vous allez
dans un service de réanimation vous
allez voir aussi des gens qui ont 40 50
ans j étais la semaine dernière on s'y
rend régulièrement avec le premier
ministre et je me permets c'est pour ça
que je reprenais la parole pour les
pour pour les femmes enceintes on a un
sujet avec des femmes en simple qui
parfois ne se font pas vacciner parce
qu'elles ont peur pour leur petit ou
parce que parfois elles sont mal
conseillé mal orienté jeu refait passer
le message est promis aux équipes de
réanimation de faire passer les équipes
à paris ou ailleurs qui ont des femmes
enceintes qui ont fait des copies de
graves parfois avec des conséquences
pour le cdh sus pour le nourrisson et
pour la mère ce sont des situations de
vie absolument terrible pour des
soignants même les plus expérimentés et
surtout pour les familles concernées
donc vraiment le message n'hésitez pas à
vous faire vacciner si vous êtes
enceinte c'est plus que possible c'est
recommandé
très bien merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
mesdames et messieurs